direction les états unis car à new york
deux projets suscitent la polémique
ainsi une mosquée mais également un
centre culturel musulman pourrait voir
le jour et cela à quelques mètres du
site de ground zero là où les deux tours
jumelles furent percutait le 11
septembre 2001 une partie des familles
de victimes des sauveteurs des pompiers
ont déjà pris position refusant ces
installations d'autres en revanche ne
comprennent pas ces amalgames et évoque
un message de paix c'est le grand format
de ce soir il est signé maryse burgot et
laurent des bois guan 0 est toujours un
immense chantier mais plus de huit ans
après l'effondrement des tours jumelles
une polémique sur ce site très sensible
divise les new yorkais
car ici à 200 mètres de ce que fut le
world trade center une mosquée pourrait
être construite
les opposants à ce projet manifesterons
dès la semaine prochaine
c'est une insulte aux victimes du
11-septembre en arabe il s'agira en fait
d'un centre culturel islamique et l'imam
à l'origine de ce projet y voient le
symbole de deux mondes réconcilier c'est
un centre communautaire et culturel
bien sûr il y aura aussi un lieu de
prière ouvert aux musulmans et à tous
c'est l'occasion d'un nouveau discours
sur les relations entre les états unis
new york et le monde musulman
mais pour certains le problème n'est pas
la tolérance
j'ai perdu mon seul frère il était
pompier
le problème selon cette mère de famille
et de respecter grand rue verreault et
sa tragédie africaine sort en tant
qu'américaine je suis tellement fier de
notre liberté religieuse mais en même
temps je pense qu'il faut respecter ce
qui s'est passé à cet endroit et à
l'interminable construction des cinq
gratte-ciel et du mémorial suscite
depuis longtemps l'impatience des new
yorkais aujourd'hui des milliers de
touristes tentent d'apercevoir le
chantier derrière ses grilles et l'idée
mosquée ne laisse personne indifférent
je peux comprendre la polémique mais en
même temps ce sera un moyen de réunir à
nouveau les gens ce pays a été fondé sur
des principes judéo-chrétien judéo
chrétien pas sûr à la ou les musulmans
non l'enjeu je suis désolé reste de
toute façon un problème de financement
l'organisation musulmane à l'origine du
projet n'a pas bouclé son budget le
maire de new york ne s'oppose pas à ce
projet et il refuse de polémiquer notre
ville dit-il est ouverte aux personnes
de toutes religions et ça s'applique
aussi au quartier de ground zero